عود الينا عصام طيبي من جديد ربما
بمزيد من المعلومات عيسى
وتابع موقع شرطه دريز انا على تويتر لغايه
هذه اللحظه لم تريد اي تحديث لكنها تؤكد
بان بانه ضرب من المواطنين من السياح عدم
الاقتراب من مركز المدينه تم اقفال طبعا
المنطقه باكملها ثم ايضا تقول الشرطه
اكرر ما قاله ما قالته الصحيفه
في الاتصال الهاتف الذي جرى بينها وبين
مدير اذاعه
تاكد بان بان المهاجم بان الاذاعه تعمل
بشكل طبيعي وبان المهاجم لم يستطيع ايقاف
بس اشاره الاذاعه وبانه تم تامين دخول
جميع العاملين الى مناصب عملهم في اذاعه
المسلح لم يتمكن من من ده الموظفين ما همم
تم تداوله وما اعلنته طبعا عن مصادرها
داخل ادريسدن همم وسائل الاعلام تتحدث عن
عن المسلحه قتل امراه تبلغ من العمر 70
عاما وصفتهم بانه الماني اا في سابقات في
احداث سابقه نتحدث عن
الاقل الاسبوع الماضي تحدث دائما احداث
كان يتحدث بان المهاجم همم لم يعرف لم
تعرف جنسيته او لم تعرف خلفياته لكن هذه
المره تبدو الاشاره مباشره
عفوا بان الماني يتحدث ان تتحدث وسائل
الاعلام بانه مواطنون المانيا يبلغ من
العمر نحو 40 عاما في عينيات همم الان
تحدث ايضا المعلومه الجديده وهو انه قام
احتجاج الرهائن في صيدليه
المعلومات السابقه تتحدث عن احتجاز رهائن
في قبو او في في الطابق السفلي
لمركز التجاري لان هناك حديث بانه يحتجز
رهين في صيدليه وبالتالي اذا عرضنا
التوفيق بين الروايات فله ربما هذه
الصيدليه موجوده داخل المركز التجاري